as fun as it is there's something rather
disturbing about scream ride obviously
you aren't supposed to take the whole
thing seriously and the people you
subject to horrible rollercoaster
tragedies seem to enjoy the whole thing
but man what about those people walking
around down there what are they even
doing walking around in this place of
death but I digress
here's the deal scream ride is split
into four chunks Racing demolition
engineering and sandbox creation sandbox
creation tools are locked behind gates
that can only be open by participating
in career events so if coaster creation
is your primary draw get ready for some
busy work
now picture a rollercoaster that gives
its riders a modicum of control over
speed and balance coaster cars with
brakes and accelerators boosting
capabilities and so forth this is the
racing part known as scream riding it
resembles traditional racing apart from
the obvious on Rails bit you're an
active participant earning boost by
pressing a button just as you near the
end of a blue stretch of track and using
an analog stick to nudge the car left or
right either to keep the car on the
track or to navigate the twists the game
throws in early on when navigation isn't
so tricky it's easy to enjoy the thrills
as your career continues the thrills
dissipate when you become more concerned
with spotting where blue tracks end so
you can earn a spot of boost screen ride
isn't really about the joys of riding
roller coasters it's about gaining as
many points as you can and showing off
your skills on the game's online
leaderboards your skin notice screen
rides biggest gameplay triumph is only
tangentially related to roller coasters
the game is big on destruction it wants
you to see colossal buildings collapsing
the voxel eyes eeap's demolition
challenges are akin to a 3d version of
Angry Birds you launch a cabin from a
rotating arm into arrangements of
structures in the hope of causing a
cavalcade of destruction and gaining
points for it explosive barrels are
tucked away in strategic places and
spires are placed to maximize damage if
you bump them in just the right way
annihilating a level is wholly
satisfying monoliths topple onto other
monoliths like a set of massive dominoes
you can always restart the level should
you miss your target doing so causes
demolished structures to be rebuilt as
you watch that could have been fun if it
didn't cause the framerate to hit rock
bottom
extensive damage
you get your build on and scream rides
engineering challenges these levels
recall the developers own rollercoaster
tycoon series plopping a coaster down on
some terrain and asking you to complete
it using a specific set of standards
there are some engineering control
quirks to contend with mostly to do with
navigating between disconnected tracks
but the interface is otherwise
commendable and it's easy to test your
coaster as you progress and then return
to construction where you can add and
twist tracks to your heart's content the
interface is usability as it its most
apparent when you delve into screen ride
sandbox which is overflowing with ways
to build coasters and environments craft
the island that your challenge rests
upon with tiles of grass and metal delve
into blueprints where you can find pre
fashioned constructs that help automate
the process screen ride asks a lot of a
controller but clear tooltips make the
process as simple as you could ask for
all of this creation is in the service
of a screen riding demolition or
engineering challenge the sandbox is
downfall is not in the breadth of its
toolset but in the limitations on how
you use it
you cannot simply build a coaster ride
it and share it for others to do the
same
not directly there are some convoluted
ways to get around the dumb restrictions
the screen rides attitude is that
rollercoasters aren't fun enough on
their own it thinks the idea of creating
and riding coasters for fun and sharing
them isn't a good fit in a game about
well creating rollercoasters and sharing
stuff
what scream ride doesn't do isn't as
interesting of the subject as what
scream ride does do it turns
rollercoaster riding into a destructive
bloodsport in which you demolish
buildings and ruin little computer
people's lives for the inherent joy of
it sometimes I think of all those
digital men and women that went
plummeting to their dooms but at least
they died doing what they love
new best screen ratings mission
successful